et comme tous les jeudis il nous a
rejoints sur ce plateau pour sa
chronique sport je vais bien sûr parler
de michael almy d'euros notre
journaliste sportif dont sort michael je
crois que vous allez nous parler de
baseball dans votre chronique du jour je
crois que vous avez dû mephishop en
début d'émission quelqu'un sixième sens
pour les chroniques sport alors
aujourd'hui je vais vous parler du
nouveau joueurs des cougars de
montigny-le-bretonneux ryan juares cet
américain de 27 ans a posé ses valises
dans la ville saint-quentinoise il ya
quelques semaines et ce n'est pas un
second couteau florane il a joué en
division 1 sied à la colle state
university northridge il a joué à berlin
en troisième division l'australie à
canberra et en première division en
belgique le californien n'a pas hésité à
signer pour le définir mon teint on
écoute
pour vous une bonne équipe nous avons
une super semaine de stage la semaine
dernière à montpellier j'ai pu voir
l'expérience de l'équipe le groupe qui
était en place et j'ai pu voir que
j'avais pris la bonne décision en venant
ici
du côté de montigny-le-bretonneux
l'équipe senior est évidemment ravi de
l'avoir recruté les cougars qui vise
clairement la montée en première
division cette saison devrait avoir
besoin de rayhana juares pour remplir
leur objectif
aujourd'hui c'est nécessaire d'avoir un
étranger
si on veut viser le plus haut niveau
notamment la d1 c'est notre objectif
notre mieux nous envie notre ambition
cette année oui c'est aujourd'hui c'est
nécessaire d'avoir un starter est un
lanceur qui va pouvoir prendre le départ
le
les dessus en tout cas sur le sur le
premier match ce qu'on a toujours deux
matchs des journées de matches et si on
peut s'assurer au moins une victoire
avec un lanceur étrangers c'est
essentiel je le disais précédemment réel
juarez sa de l'expérience en 2014 il a
été l'un des meilleurs joueurs de berne
avec des statistiques impressionnantes
le nouveau manager des cougars nous
présente ses qualités il tient vraiment
son rôle sur le monticule il est à
l'aise france ans qui a une grande
expérience il a quand même fait partie
de l'équipe nationale des philippines
qui a été jouée la voile classique c'est
compétition mondiale il ya quelques
quelques mois donc on sent vraiment
qu'il tient son rôle en suisse il a à
coeur de le faire il a envie de vraiment
de nous apporter son expérience et
aujourd'hui on est sur deux qui veut
qu'il va faire de grandes choses avec
nous rassurez-nous michael aérienne
n'est pas venu en france pour faire du
tourisme du japon il va peut-être faire
du shopping sur sont en ligne mais en
tout cas il est très professionnel il
veut conquérir le stade jean maréchal et
des montini à monter en première
division à cette année et c'est
évidemment de faire monter l'équipe en
première division que je pense que cette
équipe est assez bonne pour jouer dans
cette division et j'ai besoin de les
aider j'ai entendu que l'année dernière
n'en est pas loin de cet objectif mais
ils n'ont pas réussi à monter et je
pense que bientôt ils seront à ce niveau
avec la politique qui est mise en place
les gars peuvent faire le travail ils
sont prêts à y aller
malheureusement florane on ne devrait
pas pouvoir admirer très longtemps ce
talent brut il devrait repartir dans six
mois en australie pour poursuivre sa
carrière raison de plus pour ne pas
rater le premier match à domicile des
cougars de montier bretonne le thé le
dans votre agenda florane lésigny
montrent un contre l'équipe fédérale de
toulouse le 17 avril prochain c'est un
rendez vous que je ne manquerai pas